Philadelphia of course coming off a
rough year of 28 wins Ron 14th best
record in the West guess what we're
suckage the last seven balls are flying
Lane I'm ding brown and then lalawel for
Philly those are guys are equally
important to the well-being of their
franchises in a lot of ways Eastern 7:00
o'clock mountain time a lot of
storylines in Salt Lake City of course
were following 100 papers decision would
be a game to really has to be noticed
out there on the floor let that Dante
excellent is it's getting the job done
the pace they're playing Alan went to
the rack and folks was there to meet him
and knocked that ball away nicely well
now the question is we saw him play us
and going to his left hand and finishing
at the rim I like that I'm straightaway
picked up by Dante Exum 18 on the shot
122 to play threes on the way smooth
barrel marquel Fultz number 2 this is
just a beautiful set up here Craig yes
this about he was in traffic missing
that free throw bullets driving it end
boring great tucked around around and
this is some finishes over Damian Jones
just leans back a little bit and softly
lays it on the rim up back Center moving
to San Francisco it's going to be a
couple more seasons before that happens
but they clearly marked help folks that
was real focus and was doing a good
thing and he's helping out Indiana
working with Popeye Jones with the
patient change a job nice move inside
Kaleb Tarczewski it's Florida and that's
able to pick apart defense covington
it's for a three and I said selfish play
that time by Mark help folks give it up
to cubby kids votes beautifully Don as
he powers Shawn home buddy bendy
there is yeah there is TJ McConnell give
it a gift of full tap to the turtle
folks hangs in the air
that's a nice stop
here comes off the pick and [ __ ] drives
the car alum can't do it to the fourth
quarter
Savage - 200 volts has a checking away
by egrave these were driving down the
side double-team swatted out of bounds
by folks
[Applause]
he's done his best work Daniel's about
the minutes restrictions folks back in
the number one pick high speed
be closed it down contact that he was
able to give her the arms become close
to giving it up bed fee
beautifully done by Marjoe Poulos and
Amir Johnson boats giving up the Simmons
who floats home to the rookie goes pull
it back out
sighs that clock not the big man well it
was a much anticipated second debut for
the rookie out of Washington Park
helpful given the folks drove the jumper
and don't they love that particular flag
and more trips remember him in London as
a matter of fact him his old family
games did that love the game
[Applause]
here for the night Hardaway Cornett use
it all of that height to find him
nice little catch a nifty fit well done
by marquel colt
a he hits the short jumper and the teams
have combined already here in the
quarter for 14 three point attempts
there's Colts slamming for two and a lot
of six are partisans here in Atlanta
love annette leave and learn next time
whether its ear son at times even with
Joelle was in the lineup put on the
bench we've seen those guys play the
nominal five position if you will but
mark how thoughts comes out with
shoulder problems nicely done by marquel
faults get the piece of the rock there
and forcing the Charlotte turnover again
all the way to the cup at time playing
well in spurts with most of the time
struggling to find the rhythm
[Applause]
and they leave by six their largest
advantage comes from a great family
Mississauga Ontario we send out here to
be done by folks finishing with
in traffic there he has again shown you
that craftiness oh the nice little step
do effort about their meetings for as
well
leading scorer and Daario charge and a
foul
potentially he could add another
dimension guaranteed on Mars
fifth three-pointer in 15 tries and this
is a rookie season to Kies would after
that would rashon ed marquel blue gravy
was either made with bones or meat
byproducts or something like that
sausage is tomato sauce little oregano
little basil you notice anything
happening particularly with that team
know what I don't know if it's old
[Applause]
along with Molly Sullivan ala Hampton
Abby Mark Zubov tonight I should say I
swore I wouldn't do it again when I did
nice look marquel calls to her Sean home
folks got it back
well done by Mark cowpoke's we call it
staying with the play jump shots around
the lead with what he has been coming
back then that shoulder injury Anderson
with eight quick points right this is a
team that wants to play off its defense
they have been tremendous on that at the
floor ten on the shot clock for Winslow
outside come up with the steal Covington
got it off in time folks
oh that's a lot of sauce
that's a lot of sauce for Markel Poulsen
as wait for the Gulf kind of pressure on
lilius Silva this bolts gives it up nice
Ilyas over great look that tough the
beat keeps it alive folks he's got a
remarkable handle I'm gonna finish to
the left hand beautifully done by
marquel cookie leave those fireworks
entertaining with people come and get
into time so we want to be the best
product come back quite a play by the
way
Markel folks have to mention and it
bears repeating here on our replay quite
a chase down blocked by marquel he did
it on DJ Kennedy a Pittsburgh native
Larry something to look to the
aggressive America we played again very
it's a very much a team game as well
no doubt the athletes tell again I'm a
you know we've been around for a while
now mark body language is a big deal -
yeah it's indicative of where your state
of mind is right now is it's confident
so-called Lisfranc fracture of his left
foot ended up playing some
also in delaware bolts with a block
bolts got a piece of his arm as well
that's a great recovery one of the huge
upside
go
the hostile place
to make this is there on the clock
really next year who can they pair with
LaVon Nick off my phone's ahead to
Covington Augustine running into
Covington nice hump defense by Robert
Covington Sixers hoping for an easy two
and they get it thanks to folks off the
break at he slams for to offer the
defense getting some points Robert with
the active hands a nice pass up ahead to
zero here are the six is now leading by
five past the halfway point of the
second and bead will try another three
[Applause]
we usually see him run to the top of the
key this time running to the left wing
and you can see how mom already this
year folks all the way to the Comfort -
well done by Marco folks who has hit his
first two shots
[Applause]
back doors open for false compliments at
aureole sharukh nice little pass
bridging Jackson trying to get misses
the three here's Bullock lock from
behind
another view we are in Milwaukee
here is the honest dribbled it off his
foot lost it he did have 17 turnovers
through the first three games nice leave
from Colts most of his career with
Atlanta Hawks spent some time as Miami
bolts kind of lined to the hoop that
gave it up for clubbing tonight goes for
Robert Covington his defense once he
gets the ball up don't let him get his
back bolts all the way to the cup for -
well done by marquel folks delighting it
at number three easy finish for mr.
folks catch and release folks with the
steal Sixers look to go in front Joelle
folks all the way in and he slams for
two off the break the kill does the
right thing you eat up that space attack
him
Markel co2 rim protection
Joell not there is Wow folks
grabbing that one through he is
undergoing the NBA concussion protocol
Kawhi Leonard is being arrested as
bullets on a would delivers twofold in
it folks exploring opportunities against
little Williams it has his way dropsy
right because the guy can't move
it's the offensive other player guy
that is a terrific play by folks sixes
we are through three sixes by four
fourth quarters coming up
be wary number 23 in the Sixers great
show nice block by folks brilliant save
the Sharks well done by Mark Kelly those
long arms
Huffington it's for three here's that
play again you very rarely block your
own man shot and then the save it in and
then down the other end lead the charge
for three from deep folks took it away
from this Smith muscala yes wall key is
the bag that something will keep our eye
on as this game progresses the defense
by Bogdanovich to knock it away young in
transition and Ben Simmons has a little
room service slam dunking fit free
George they're gonna have to use up a
bunch of fouls to slow him down pulls
denied spin move and finished with the
left hand and that's him at his best
tipped up by Chandler and a reset on the
shot clock down to 14 of course bolts
the nice crossover and punch
denied by her nan Gomez went up on the
deck bolts on the deck came up with a
steel somehow got it to Simmons who
throw it down rollin and assist to Ben
Simmons miss Marcal folks plays that
open areas you think you get to better
me there's a loose ball that I still get
a part of watch this get to the floor
first
nice little nutmeg pads child kind of
forgot that responsibility been with
easy to well done by folks to block the
shot of Conley Anderson faced a
hard-nosed guy before the duck
good defense by the Sixers in closing on
Conley sixer lead down to four bolts
going for it count it and a foul looks
like he got both determined move
athletic ability able to avoid the
contact and at the same time get the
ball up to the glass and Kyle Anderson
and Karen Jackson jr. and of course mark
to saw little fake trapped by Jojo there
the food this all off led to the
turnover and folks is able to finish the
job so the Sixers turning on the road
got to rely on the ones in the Box hole
with the heat will take their share it's
a new style of play more up-tempo and
shooting a lot of threes it's bolts to
the wood as Chandler buries the three
compliments of Mark Hill folks that said
the six is only three turnovers by the
way only one Cudahy great effort by mark
Cal folks and that effort will be
rewarded with one more at the line
English should you dub because there's
an awful lot of English on this one oh I
still kiss off the glass high degree of
difficulty to finish in traffic mister
folks Johnson's give and go is sham it
one more for folks twirled into pretty
finished by marquel volts you see how
well the Scala moved that time against
Tony Parker true Parker's the quick guy
he used to be his folks took some
punishment I was able to get a tough to
the other way a number of them before
the game you get to see your favourite
team here twice a year is full slice
defense on Parker
Simmons working it with Korkmaz who laid
it home sham it for three bolts posting
in there when a play by marquel folks
who got it to muscala for the slam
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content